- They're all doing this stuff.
They all do this taking
away the driver's license.
They all do the you have
to pay to be on probation.
It's just shocking.
There's 43 states in this country
where you have to pay money
to have a public defender.
That seems impossible,
but that is the truth.
So that's the one whole piece here
is that this is a national issue.
The other part is that it's metastasized
into a whole bunch of other things
because now we don't just
kick kids out of school,
suspend them or expel them.
We send them to court,
and we've been doing that
really since Columbine in a big way.
And so it's the whole pipeline to prison.
It's now got a fast lane for it.